Juliet está trabajando en un reportero.
escuela usando un procesador
palabras el que potencia una figura que
tiene 13,09 centímetros de ángel de
de la forma que quieras y centrado en la página de
página y 21 puntos 59 centímetros
mientras que el margen debe salir a la izquierda
de modo que la figura que está centrada en
abierto tenemos lo que tenemos somos
diciendo que tenemos un documento de 21 puntos
59 centímetros por aquí
ahora vamos a poder papelear eso normalmente
no podemos dejar en blanco los honores de papel
suelen ser papel blanco de estos
tamaño del papel porque es muy común
ahora el japones de la figura y digamos que
la figura del equipo de marfil de aprendamos
mas o menos para los que quieren centrar
mas o menos seria como somos
entonces lo que quiero saber es el
pregunta generada esta a partir de la figura y ronan a
Ángel de 37 puntos y distancia centrada
igual distancia
si estas dos distancias son iguales
nosotros es papel es 21 puntos 59
centímetros 21,50 web antes de la figura
con enlaces 13 puntos
webb si se quedara del 2011 en el punto 59
13.09 entonces solo tendería a la suma de estos
dos distancias
sí este marketing margen izquierdo
recto y luego si tomo esto
distancia ea medida entre las obtiene diría
exactamente esta distancia que estoy
búsqueda y bento en el punto 59 - 13
puntos y bruno m
este es exactamente el tio punto 50
centímetros y ahora este juego se divide
entra el sonido otra forma de verlo y si
Yo multiplicaría am por un promedio
punto 5 en el mismo pastel de hotel que
distancia que estoy buscando entonces si
elige a samita de otro punto 5 del año
parlamentario de otro punto 5 y 6 4 punto
25 centímetros y servimos exactamente eso
lo buscábamos marca izquierda
tendrá que ser de 4,25 centímetros y
obviamente esta distancia estelar o
será también de 4,25 centímetros y como
estoy
terminamos